what a what a what a what an
absolute what a aad aad what an
[Music]
absolute a what a lad well with the
nation going crazy with this up thew
movement I thought it was time to get
some warriors on what a lad and who
better than probably my all-time
favorite Warrior and won many regard as
one of the best Lads to have ever played
the game he played six seasons for the
Warriors coming off The Back Fence with
intent each year before spending a year
with the Raiders and shooting over to
the UK where he spent a season with the
Vikings he announced his retirement from
League at just 28 years old and since
then has transformed himself into a
full-on entrepreneur having started up
his own portaloo company Porter Kings
which has obviously taken over the world
what a lad this guy is it is of course
the great man Charlie gab welcome mate
yeah thanks Jimmy thanks for having me
but um you I've been pretty pretty
nervous all week or been nervous for a
year since you since you asked me to
come on I reckon it's been like almost
two years since we sort of pened it in
but mate what a day this is finally got
you on what a Le how good yeah no it's
good I um I've been following since day
one and obviously started over h a and I
was like H you know you had some good
lads on they got a bit more lad on them
than me and then I could see your um
guest list you know slowly slowly coming
down to my level and um I think um you
know it's offseason so you're probably
doing that pretty tough and I don't know
head I can't push you off for so long oh
well I think this one's going to be
massive because I've heard a few of your
stories before a few of your Yarns and M
it's oh some alltime stuff there but
like I mentioned in the intro porter
porter Kings um I guess not many people
um would P sort of put you you as a
portaloo entrepreneur business owner but
how did you get into that yeah it
definitely wasn't something I was um
planning when sitting lifetime dream
yeah you know when they when the when
the old boys come in and talk to you
when you're plan they're like oh you
know you should start
something it wasn't um I definitely
didn't have like a poof fetish or
anything like that but um it just kind
of happened I was um doing a bit of
civil construction waiting for concrete
one day and me being me I just always
yarning to everyone and the poalo guy
came and I was talking to him he was a
freaking character then um I don't know
I just started I was thinking oh how
much is your does your boss make money
he goes yeah he's Rich ass and I was
like could be a good copy and paste idea
here and um yeah just just went with it
really so what decided you to make that
leap because obviously you know people
always have sort of ideas or they're
like oh man that could be a cool
business or whatever but not many people
actually follow through with those sort
of ideas but you obviously have and
you've set it up and going strong yeah I
don't know like I joke about it but I
think Underneath It All there's kind of
that feeling like once you finish 40
like I finished I I wanted to finish
but you have that um feeling when you're
going to work like I don't know I did
anyway after a couple years like man is
this is this my life now I just freaking
get up and go to work and then come home
and get ready for work again so yeah it
was I was always wanting to do something
with a bit of purpose
um whatever it was like I didn't really
it didn't really matter just wanted kind
of something to work towards like in
footy you know you're um working towards
obviously the goal to win a comp and
then there's a process to get there you
get up every day and do that whereas
like work I was just going through the
motions so kind of had the idea and I
had good people around me too I'm not
like 100% owner um and we just kind of
fed off each other and it just gave me a
bit of drive so without being too
serious that's probably what it was and
like underneath it all just the drive to
um I don't know just have something to
work towards and build yourself rather
than just get extra freaking 50 cents at
the end of the year yeah and what did
you know about business did you know
anything or were you going in pretty
cold uh both my parents always ran small
business growing up I always um my old
man had like a CH boat and was like
fishing but mostly parties oh yeah and
then yeah I was working on that pretty
much since since I was at primary school
I remember um running I used to run the
bar this is what was always cash bar and
then I remember taking the um like the
National Police out and I was running
the bar and the guy was like I think I
was 13 he was like are you 18 and I was
like yeah yeah I'm 18 and he goes oh
that's all right mate I look like you
and I was 18
[Laughter]
too what did you look like oh just a
little freaking fat
CH yeah I don't know pretty much look
like the guy that you wouldn't want your
daughter to bring home You' be pretty
embarrassing so you said you're on that
boat from about five that's pretty young
he like handling money yeah yeah yeah so
just got brought up on that obviously
pocketing a bit here and there um but
yeah just brought up around that I think
even when I was playing in on my dad
would make me come home and work in in
the offseason I used to hate it man just
I I always found it embarrassing you
know like but I just I guess it gives
you no ego freaking serving serving kids
on their 18th birthday and you're 24
years old inl play and you're like oh
would you like a spring
[Laughter]
roll that's probably why I got so many
questions for the end about um the this
boat is what's it called it's got a name
isn't it oh it's called sweet George he
doesn't have it anymore but I think he
got a he got pushed out of all the red
tape not allowed to have underage labor
anymore oh it's good stuff but well we
obviously heard a little bit about your
um upbringing from when you're about
five but take me back to even earlier
than five you know how I like to do this
on the podcast give me the sort of
rundown of Charlie gab as a we as a we
toddler man I actually don't remember um
being a toddler is that
normal um casions yeah concussion yeah
that's what it'll be uh no what do I
remember about being a kid just just one
brother one sister yeah um yeah my old
man was always away working on the boat
um he used to do heaps of trips down sou
at that time like fishing and anything
anything to earn a dollar and I think uh
um I don't know I just remember like
being at home and ringing my mom at work
asking like hey can we heat up a
microwave
Pizza no wait till I get
home yeah just those sort of memories I
remember oh good memories yeah good
memories I like obviously I don't know
if you remember but that was when
Toppers were a big thing Toppers oh yeah
yeah yeah CAU on blur which I still
smash now the frozen ones is it the
frozen ones yeah I get the ones from BP
now I think my body's probably 15%
caught on
Blue yeah we are wi as a kid
yeah yeah now just playing footy I was
um lucky enough to live close to heaps
of friends who ended up being good footy
players oh right so we're always at the
park with um the Proctors and as I got
older freaking Jordan Kaho and Lima
saanga we used to um we didn't really
know each other that well but we used to
meet up at the park oh and man we had
some intense battles and uh we were Town
boys and they were hot boys and we
always just sent them home packing
crying momy and
Daddy because you mentioned your brother
your brother's older than you right yeah
he's a year old yeah true so you you
guys must had a lot of battles even like
when you weren't meeting up with the
Proctors and sangers of the world was it
just you you and your brother Peter is
it going head to-head yeah yeah Peter
yeah yeah
yeah what do we used to do growing up
well we used to always just play hallway
rugby yeah you know just narrow
hallway um for a few holes on the wall
crying my dad would always just I don't
know he was I think he just used a fro
on
it yeah so we play bit of that
outside um yeah we used to have some big
battles me and Peter and it would always
um I don't know it was it was crack up
that sort of stuff is like funny but you
don't really remember it until you're
bringing it up now Jimmy yeah do were
you good at like as a young fellow were
you good no I wasn't my brother was good
and I used to get on the um rep teams
cuz he was good he was like one of those
super fast for his age group kids oh
yeah and then um I guess they're like ah
you can bring your
brother oh were you're the same age
group though yeah yeah yes I used to
play I used to play up I'm pretty sure I
used to play up oh you must have you
must have been good
no I actually wasn't I remember um like
what the year before it goes to tackle
must be like under sevens like he scored
like so many tries and then and then it
was like towards the last game of the
year someone passed it to me and I put
it down but I put I put it down at the 5
met
line it was my only opportunity to score
and I just remember going home and
crying my dad was like Hey you made some
good
touches and you still made the rep to
oh yeah as we got I don't think they do
R for under s but definitely wouldn't
have got pulled into that one I was
going to say handing it
out yeah be it's pretty much like
handing out the deli
in oh that is funny and were you quite a
big softball player too by the sounds of
things yeah yeah I always love softball
um I played up
until maybe I was 16 oh yeah and then I
I remember
actually I thought I was pretty good at
softball and then there was like a like
a North iseland team and um I remember
tring for
it and TJ pinar's old man Thomas was the
coach oh yeah and I was like Wai didn't
you know they at the thing they're like
oh you know if you make it you're going
to hear from us if you don't we'll call
you and he called me and he was like you
are the hardest one not to pick I just
remember being like in my head [__] you
brother and then um oh after that I
didn't want to play anymore I was got to
DJ Brother the old man got me out of
softball could have been a black sock
but
um I actually um turns out I wasn't that
good apparently but were you better at
softball than you were um League or
rugby at the time yeah yeah oh true yeah
oh I don't I don't actually know like
cuz obviously there was probably about
10 guys playing softball on Wellington
and I was I was probably you know in the
top
five yeah and then how did the sort of
rugby progress cuz I know you're a bit
of a rugby union star for Wellington
College eventually yeah I don't know
about star but I did I always love
playing rugby um at school and then it
kind of you know you don't jump in the
lineups and that when you're a junior
and stuff like that and then all the
technique stuff comes in and I C kind of
started falling behind but um I remember
I played like under 65s when I was 5if
form oh yeah I child for the under 15s
but didn't make the a team so I just
played league and rugby at the same time
league on Sundays oh yeah played for
Harbor City played hooker and I remember
fre I I think I took maybe like one
scoot the whole season I was just
dishing it off the ground off the ground
but every now and then Julian would come
play for us and then would just carve
yeah it was one of those teams where
like one week you might lose by 80 and
then you get around people get their
mates to come and then you have a good
red hot crack versus Team like RAM and
um you nearly knock him over and then
you're like oh yeah man you guys going
to come next week and they're like
nah okay all good did you see a pathway
for yourself as a rugby union or League
player at the time um I think I always
had goals to but like
whether they're delusional or not I
don't I'm not sure you know like every
obviously not yeah obviously not now but
at the
time like being the size I was and
probably the skill level I was at that
everyone would have been like
no no mate yeah but um yeah no I just
held on to the dream obviously I
remember I had I had a good big uh
growth spit in my last year of
school and um that was around the same
time that Toyota cup started on TV oh
yeah yeah and I remember freaking I was
like obsessed with the Toyota cup and I
always just was like man I want to play
that one day blah blah blah even though
I wasn't even like playing freaking
League or anything I want to play Toyota
cup like what team we used to have me
and my brother cuz we [__] a room up
until uh oh I must have been 19 when I
left
home yeah yeah yeah and we used to have
the all the posters up and the light
will be off okay we we'll go name forame
on every team yeah have little
competitions like that like and I'll be
like Russell Packer B melino and then
we'll get down to um freaking all the
out ofit names but
um and you'll be like he's not on the
team list turn the light on look at it
he
is yeah so had a few of those battles in
there but um yeah no I always had a
dream to um to play the to in the Toyota
cup which up happening so that's crazy
so you were like a fullon rugby league
fan and Union as well or was it mainly
League was that your main like passion I
don't know I like I'm I was like a fan a
union fan of like my school teams like
used to watch the first5 and be like
[__] you know like we had buckon at our
school I just thinking like man buxton's
the man and I see him do you want my
sandwich like you know try and get to
know um and then we had like Dane Kohl's
I remember Dane Cole's starting a fight
at school and I just like man I got to
do that like I got to start more
fights the stuff I don't know yes I
wasn't really like looking up to uh any
genuine rugby players at the time it was
more just like school boy Stars yeah
that's crack out so we did you start
getting in a few more fights after
witnessing the niggle goat and action
from a young age yeah definitely
definitely and I was always pressed to
uh to to to instigate it from old man
which I don't know like anything it just
manifests itself even if you don't want
it
to oh jeez so then how do you end up at
the warriors with the under 20s
eventually oh I left school and then I
started playing for the hunters which is
like the local cuz Harbor City who was
was playing for as a junior they
folded I think they had too many um
Mobsters so they were you know know
seasonal players in and out but um so I
went to the
hunters and had some like real mean
senior players around me and then just
like not mean players but just like mean
like you know hardcore rugby league
dudes that teach you tip fortat that
sort of stuff and um I was playing for
them and they were saying oh you know
you should uh there were weren't many
young kids playing so they're like you
know you could make it you could make it
and I'm the I'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but all the best kids are
playing Union um and I ended up playing
for the orcas men's team that year true
um and then I just made my own video and
sent it to cuz people kept telling me
like oh the Raiders are watching this
team's watching they're going to talk to
you and I was thinking like yeah they
must be because these people are saying
it but it got to like the end of the
season I had nothing and I was like [__]
like real
deflated and then I was like maybe they
weren't watching
maybe these guys are just all [__] which
they were um so I just made like a
highlight video of just
faking was wasn't much highlights there
was no line breaks it was just kind of
like aggressive stuff like a kid like
trying to start a fight with a guy
that's going to go my hiding and then um
all the clubs that I sent it to got back
because I sent it to all the Aussie
clubs oh that's right and then um I
think someone from the Titans sent it to
some cuz I didn't send it to the
Warriors cuz I was like man if these
guys didn't see me playing in the
national comp or they did see me they're
not going to want to watch my video yeah
um but they sent it to John eckan then
he rang me um said you want to come up
for a trial he was the first one that
got back oh yeah and I was like yeah
yeah I'll come up so I went up and
stayed up there and like the sheare
house they had like a a house that was
owned by um I think it was owned by like
Clinton
torpy and they just like put the kids in
there not kids but like 18 like first
year away from home and like no parent
no kle or anything and like I remember
it was just like washing from like Benny
Matt's reckons it was from like his
first year there which was like 4 years
before like the Wash House was just like
so ratchet like holes in the floorboards
and I was sleeping in this room outside
that was all um it was all glass it was
like a glass house yeah and it was so
hot like and the sun would come up at
like 5:00 a.m. I'd just be like [__]
like dad ring like how's I was like yeah
no I get him up early every
day it was uming scod and then um yeah
they got I got dragged along the whole
preseason and then that's when the other
Aussie clubs they sent some um offers
through and then I just went up to Jon
say oh I'm going to go to the Tigers and
he was like no mate stay here blah blah
blah gave me a contract so yeah ended up
staying staying there the year F right
that's crazy so you've cut your own clip
sent them to every NRL team and um got
your contract that way that's that's
crazy he yeah yeah it is crazy I was
lucky I had um like my old man pushing
me because that was back in the day
where like you didn't really have a
computer I had to um just take
DVDs of games and write down like 1
minute 20 seconds and I took it to like
a film producer he like he like cut it
off cuz you had to have like a I don't
know V know how it worked but I was like
dubbing
tape and then I just got I got 16 16
DVDs printed and I CED them to Australia
with a reference from my mate who um my
mate Tim kill who played B card with
Benny Melina and there and Russell he
was like I've played with Ben and Russ
and he's in the same
caliber like give you have my word blah
blah blah and they're like you got a
good reference blah blah blah we'll give
you a contract all right that is crazy
yeah and then so you you go to the
Warriors you sign up there and is that
the year you're playing Toyota cup yeah
yeah yeah
so I don't know must have been
2010 um yeah straight into it Toyota cup
so cool like playing and I every second
week traveling over like I don't know it
was just all new like everything's new
like going on a plane as a team and the
competition was good like the players
like all oh yeah it was just cool like
when you at like the Grand Final players
were playing against the semi-final
they're all like the stars now so it was
just cool rubbing shoulders and then
getting to know those guys did you feel
like you were good enough to be there
because obviously it had happened all
pretty quick for you I did cuz I was um
cuz I was playing men's and they were
the boys that were playing were mostly
playing age grade true so when when I
came into it they were like oh you're
playing men blah blah blah but I felt
and my I had confidence in my own self
like
that I was like a good a good 20s player
yeah and I was always like super
aggressive and um just did everything
that if the coach told me to do
something I'd do it that's kind of what
I yeah I wasn't I didn't doubt myself at
under 20s level yeah but then obviously
when you make the step up is that when
um it all sort of the confidence levels
sort of um get a bit of reality check
yeah yeah I guess so I remember getting
to the end of the season and they were
kind of like I'm in an iron Ivan Ivan
was the NR coach at the time and know
I'm in an iron if I was going to get
resigned and then I think John Hart was
like the director of football oh yeah
and then he goes
oh I think you still need to do like
your apprenticeship like you're still
doing a lot of things wrong goes go over
to Australia and then come back next
year and I was like uh nah I think I'll
just go and work on the boat oh really
were you looking to give it up yeah cuz
I don't want to go to Australia without
like cuz most of our team got in ourl
contracts CU we won yeah how many like
what sort of percentage got them well I
think out of the 17 that played the
Grand Final 15 went on to play NRL oh F
yeah so it was pretty high percentage
and
probably maybe 13 got NRL contracts or
all were young enough to play again so I
was just like there was a couple of
other boys that did what I did went over
and played cup and then ended up kicking
on but I don't know it kind of like DSE
your confidence a bit like when you see
like your friends going this way and
you're kind of going sideways yeah but
um yeah I ended up going over to Wi
Manley anyway um my manager at the time
FR indicot he sort of that out I didn't
even know really know what it was um the
Queensland cup I was just thinking like
oh it's just like local league in
Australia and then I got there I flew
over and and then the same thing stayed
in a house that they had um was like
home real homesick but started working
at the Port straight away like unloading
containers freak it was just so hard so
it wasn't wasn't a um League contract
you were still working it was a contract
like I think I maybe got I maybe get
like 800 bucks a game or something and
then free accommodation but it wasn't
really like you I wasn't looking at it
like oh this is all good for a game it
was like I just want to play NRL and but
they keep saying like oh this is the NRL
then the next what best is quinland cup
but you don't know because You' never
heard of it yeah and then um remember
going to training and just being like Oh
yeah I'll try and freaking bully these
guys and then I was just getting [__]
smoked yeah like they it's not till you
get over that you realize like how tough
the Aussie League guys are they're just
it might be the same of Union I don't
know but the the Ley like all through
the grades they just freaking tough
tough and just they came for a scrap
they just I don't know they different
different toir Eric and they're just
hard yeah so is that uh you look back at
that um sort of year over there and
think it was like the best thing for
you um yeah at the time I didn't cuz we
um Paul Green was our coach um who just
passed away and you know the Cowboys
coach and there he was um man he was is
a awesome coach but we lost our first
few games and I was thinking like man
stuff this um but stuck on we ended up
winning quite a few in a row and then we
won um we ended up winning the final and
I was like I remember having like a a
pretty good game in the final just doing
not a good game but I did like a lot of
big hits and for me that was like yeah
I've had a mean game that's good
highlights to send to your next your
next clubs yeah yeah I always just used
to
like catch up with like my mates back in
Oakland be like oh how'd you go and I
just send him just video to my T they're
like mean bro you're going to get picked
up soon but really like I'm just walking
everywhere yeah so was like that and
then I didn't get anything and I came
home and I was like I can't go again
like I um like if I didn't get picked up
we just one the can't my dad was like
you going again don't forget while
you're there blah blah blah I was like
then my head I'm like [__] you
but um no it was good for me I went back
over oh did you do two years I went I
did two years yeah that next year I went
over and I trained so hard I remember
like being in my room and I just run I
would just run most nights even though
we' do like a tough a preseason I'd kind
of like have dinner and then we get to
like 11:00 at night and I'll just go for
a road run and I remember just getting
super fit and playing pretty much whole
preseason games and having mean mean
stats which I didn't used to have yeah
um and then I played for the Queensland
residence team which is pretty much like
the Queensland team that hasn't played
more than a few NRL games so there's
lots of NRL players in there in
Queensland Cup players and then that was
cool and I was like oh made the
Queensland team surely I'll get picked
up and then we won the final again that
year um and they had a good game and
nothing happened and then I was
like [__] like what's what's doing um
and I ended up bringing I remember just
being like real [__] off of like just
life in general yeah and then I was like
man the Warriors said that I would come
back you know i' D picked me up again
and I remember ringing them up and being
like hey like I talked to Dean B and I
was like you said if I go go away then
you'll pick me up again when I learn the
game I said you know I played for and
residence and blah blah blah like naming
the stuff like they care but he was like
oh did we who said that like and he was
like oh he goes oh come back for a trial
he goes come back to the preseason not
paying you and I was like oh yeah okay
sweet so I ended up um texting my mate
Sam lousy he's like yes come live with
me and I was like okay sweet so I
freaking went to his house and slept on
the floor between him and his brother
the whole preseason man I got bit by
like a thousand
fleas no [__] like you know when you get
goosebumps like how many bumps you have
that was flea bites for
me like the fleas were probably like
holy heck we got some freaking white
meet here let's go let's go boys just
went to town on you the F yeah man I was
the opposite of Mortin bro they loving
me they went to town I was freaking
embarrassing I remember turning up to
preseason um and everyone was like oh
gby haven't seen you since blah blah
blah anyway they're like okay we're
going out to the track um you got to
wear your old gear they' sent out a
message like you got to we old Warriors
gear and I had nothing and the guy the
manager who still the manager now Dan
Floyd he goes oh come to the office I
got some gears I was like [__] yeah I'm
going to get Warriors gears straight
away and he pulled out the rankest old
Polo shirt like for promos you gave me
that and like um just training train the
training shs all right and the shoes
were like those like just big bulky
Asics that you'd wear like our old man
would wear like cross country walking
and I was like [__] okay all good like
put it on and then we head to like this
is when Matt Elliot came yeah and then
they were saying like oh you know the
Warriors have a bro culture like we're
going to train that out of you boys blah
blah blah and I was like what what's
going on here and we ended up the first
session we did like
2100s yeah and and then we did um 15
200s then 10 400s oh and people were
just collapsing like people were just
collapsing I remember civa havil just
like leaning on the fence the whole time
and we were just so [__] and then
they're like all right sweet into
wrestling now this was all new to me
like into wrestling did wrestling and
they're like okay back to the field
Ruben wi's taking use for this freaking
whatever it is that he was doing how
were you going at this point were you
still were you dominating it I was going
hard like I was going so hard hard
because I was on trial like and I was
like these guys are watching me but I
looking back they were probably just
like they're probably like who's this
guy who's who's the guy on the
PO fans come to train with us yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're probably like oh
that's nice someone's someone's brought
this kid along that's
nice oh yeah but um yeah I I went so
hard it was me there was a couple of us
on trial me S Matangi um Nate
petu um and a couple of other guys who
were just real crack up um ockland club
guys yeah and then um yeah I just
remember me and sa were always having
battles like we were just we were just
just train so hard like and just push
ourselves to the Limit every single
session because we're like oh you know
they we've only got one
chance obviously he would he probably
had a bit more fur in the belly just
coming out of
prison here's me here's me coming over
from hey why you pick me
up but you're coming off the flea floor
oh yeah just as tough yeah yeah they
probably I was probably like blood
doping from the from the
police it's probably more comfortable in
[Laughter]
prison yeah true I should ask him about
that what's the food like in prison oh
yeah you got
fleas
yeah no where we where will we Jammer
what a pathway though like that's
unbelievable so you're winning
everything you win the Toyota cup you go
over to Aussie you win two comps over
there you can do no wrong you're playing
well you're smashing everyone and it's
still a real battle for you to make it
back into the Warriors it seems like
almost unfair oh in my mind it was
unfair but um yeah I I actually don't
know what it was there was obviously
something like I probably wasn't the
well I don't think the Warriors are were
looking in the Queensland cup anyway
like I don't think that's they kind of
just have such a big nurser in Oakland
you know what I mean and they still had
really good 20s players coming through
yeah they're probably like oh we didn't
sign them Charlie
here J Who what the guy on the Polar did
he just to play for us he be like yeah M
when the can't what the [__] but um yeah
I don't know they just weren't weren't
weren't looking and then yeah I did get
opportunity to do the preseason and um
obviously went went ham and I remember
what do I remember I remember the trial
I did play cuz you kind of just get one
trial when you're a young guy or a guy
on trial and then because of injuries I
got to trial in the in the end game
where the best players play you know the
round one team and I only got 10 minutes
at the end versus the Broncos down in
Den but
um the warriors were already winning and
I got on in the last 10 and I think the
Broncos were already like pretty naed so
like I ended up having a good trial and
I scored a try which was probably my
first try ever and then I was like holy
I just got to try and the NRL TR like
surely surely is anyone watching and
then um and then didn't hear anything
and then I remember walking to training
like a week or two later and then Dean B
just pulled hit me up in um the car park
and then he was like do you do you want
to be a warrior and I was like yeah and
he was like yeah sign this sign us
didn't even took me for the contract I
was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah and he was like sweet you've
just signed for two years and I was like
okay sweet thanks mate all right just
like that damn just like that yeah
signed up in the car
park and I remember ringing ringing
Frank indart the manager and I go oh
Dean just gave me a uh I just signed his
contract he was like how much is it and
I was like whatever I think I was like
55 grand and match payments or something
and he was like that's not too bad not
too bad I was like yeah thanks for
sorting that out really it wasn't you
know no idea about it yeah and did you
play that year was that the year you're
instantly into it yeah yeah well I
played New South World's Cup most of the
year I looking back I wasn't in the top
25 so you're not allowed to play until
there's no one in the top
25 that can cover that position
okay um not that I should have been
playing or anything but I ended up
playing when um what happened I kept
being 18 this is what happened this is
what happened Jam
um um I kept being 18th man yeah um cuz
I was I was going well in cup we had a
good cup team um ockland Vulcans um and
I enjoyed playing that we used to travel
to Sydney every week and play Fly
Emirates and there was like heaps of
club guys there so they would always
just get on the piss Heavy after the
game yeah um and I was just like a mad
[__] I would just
follow um and then Emirates that
everyone would just get on it on the way
back blah blah blah like the N boys used
to love coming down and playing cup cuz
you get so looked after and like no one
at that stage no one was no one was
watching like they weren't they would
never be like hey freaking who who
played cup recently I don't know it
wouldn't be like oh floody Mato is
pissed at the
airport it was just like the Norms yeah
and then um I remember just playing that
and then they go oh you're 18th man you
got in over to Perth and I was like oh
yeah sweet this will be all right go to
P fly first class which was first time
went over and then um they didn't say
anything about playing and then till the
night before the game they go ah and by
the way I think it was been Russell or
something oh Russell's pulled out and
gb's going to debut and I remember just
being like like I was just so shocked
yeah just so pumped it was like such a
crazy amount of emotion just come over
you cuz you're not expecting it like he
had I hadn't been prepping the whole
week I think I probably just I don't
know just been eating CAU on blues and
up and goes it wasn't I wasn't you know
on that match foot diet but it's all up
here Jam and how did you go yeah I went
good and and yeah like not many games I
can say went good but my debut I went
good we played versus the
rabitos and I remember they had like Sam
Buress oh all the Buress Brothers Greg
englas they had a freaking mean team
Isaac Luke at Hooker who was like my
favorite player at the time and remember
I got on and I went to do like the
kickoff run and it went like so high and
like 90 caugh it real close to the line
and then he like I was just steaming
onto it and then like he dummied it and
I was like [__] yeah and then like as I
was saying like [__] you for not passing
Sam buris was just like flew past me and
I was
like that was like that could have been
the first and last of myl career if he
had given it so Nuggie Nugget had a
freaking he had a game that game too I
remember he bumped off um Reynolds and
knocked them out but yeah I was just I
was it was all a blur like even when I
was tired you know just keep going so it
was just mean and you did play what 39
games for the Warriors so like pretty
good tell in the end um yeah what were
your favorite moments um I just there
was so much fun times yeah like in the
team rooms you know on away trips at
training and stuff but there were also
like some man we had some tough Seasons
like
we I think we went through three coaches
that pretty much says how [__] we are in
one year oh we did go for yeah maybe
yeah yeah yeah cuz mat Elliott didn't
last a year yeah then keppy came he got
thrown on the deep end and he I thought
he was a main coach but um the results
just didn't go his way and then um
Steven KY came later on but um what were
the mean memories I don't know I I you'd
have to bring some stories I I could
just imagine you being one of those guys
who did love like um the the team
camaraderie you know the I've heard that
you're always the last man um to leave
the sort of Team base always just
yarning to the lads or telling stories
and just loving the company of all the
other boys yeah for sure that that I
think that was definitely the highlight
of uh my career the locker room moments
and that's probably where I did my best
work on the uh on the group chats and
whatnot yeah yeah I I do miss miss the
group chats and um I don't no I used to
just go to yeah like you say go to
training early and just like link up
with whoever was
around and they'll be like stretching on
the rolline I'll be like pop
up where'd you come
from and you obviously grew a pretty big
following too as well like um the fans
loved you they loved something about you
where they all sort of got them behind
you and Charlie gab was like a lot of
guys favorite players yeah I think it
was um from Mount smart probably
probably just the intensity I always
just was just like the complete opposite
to how I was off the field once I was on
the field man I was just so intense and
did some crazy [__] that I'm like why
why did I do that but um and also like I
used to get smashed a lot too which they
probably um respected you know like oh
man he can get smashed I can get smashed
like they're just a fan of the everyday
man having a crack yeah and did you love
that did you love that side of the game
just running it hard running getting
smashed smashing people um not really
yeah like I didn't
really game day was definitely my least
favorite day of the week like oh true
yeah yeah cuz I used to get like like
real bad anxiety before the games once I
was playing I was sweet but it was just
the buildup I remember like even even
since I left home like my old man would
always ring me like on a Tuesday and I'd
be like [__] he's ringing and he' just
like stopped trying to J me up like
Vince Lombardi like on a Tuesday and I'd
be like stop doing us like and he'll be
like and go [__] hard and I just
remember like try just trolling I'm not
going to go hard I'm not even going to
try you know and just he'd take it
seriously and be so fired up and then my
mom would text me like oh Dad Dad says
you're not going to
try but um obviously I ended up going
hard and he probably put that fire on
the belly but um
yeah I don't know where were
we that's funny cuz you uh cuz then what
what what ended up happening there like
you end up going to the Raiders what
happened at the Warriors why' you leave
oh so what actually happened was I had
signed a 2-year contract
um before Steve Kerney had got Steve KY
had got there oh yeah and then
um there was kind of like an era like
pretty much like my first one I didn't
read it properly he was probably like
[__] let's just pull the wall over this
guy's eyes and then I signed it and then
read it and I was like oh actually in
the second year I get less than the
first year like it was all to do with
match payments like if I paid played
like say 15 games which I ended up doing
in the first year then my second year is
not even worth as much and then Dean B
was the guy in charge of um and he was a
good dude like me Dean me de like that
he was like oh if you do do that he goes
if you do play 15 I'll just screw it up
and we'll renegotiate and I was like
okay sweet but I didn't put it on paper
but like me Frank Endicott and him shook
hands and Wayne scar was in there whever
he says he was or not he was in there
and um and then I played the 15 games
and it came to the preseason next year
and um thing got the sack um or he got
pushed or he left on his own terms I
don't know Dean Bell left and then um
Jim Doyle came in and started running it
and it was like I was on like [__]
myy um so like every little bit helped
and I was like oh Jim this is the deal
blah blah blah and he goes oh it's not
on paper and I go yeah but it's a
handshake like it's a handshake
handshake is a handshake yeah and then
he was like oh we'll look into it so I
started doing kind of the
preseason um and then I was like are you
looking into it and he was like mate
like
mate like get out of here like not thing
and I remember just thinking like man
[__] you're so full of [__] you [__]
like that's what that's it I'm pretty
intense when I fli the switch and then I
was just off him and then um Steve
KY um came that year and when he when he
first got there he goes oh I don't see
you on my team like which is fair enough
he told me like pretty much on the first
day like you can go look for another
in our club and I was like guttered
because I like loved the Warriors and I
was going good like had played pretty
much the whole season the season before
under
keppy and I got suspended so I had like
heaps of time off I was training hard
and then he came in and was like oh I
don't see you on my team which I respect
because he get told me early and then I
ended up um couple days later getting a
two-year contract with the sharks and I
was like oh I need you to sign the
release and then he goes oh I just found
out that the club's got a policy we
can't release you until um until we've
signed a
replacement and then I was like okay
sweet and then I left and I got home and
I was thinking man how are they going to
find an experienced front row on minimum
wage and then I was like keep going to
training and I was going like have you
found anyone and he was like not yet
mate it's it's looking like we not going
to find anyone and I was like thinking
like man what the hell cuz preseason so
hard like you have to be extremely
motivated to get through NL preseason
and I was
like it was hard to bust my ass when the
coaches pretty much said like you're not
on the team you're just here because we
can't replace you and I was like I ended
up stopped going to training for a bit
because I wanted to I wanted them to rip
my contract up so I could shoot off to
the Sharks which was on I was like
triple the money over there and wanted
and then M changes mind he goes oh
actually you're going to start round one
and I was like change a tune I was like
okay that's all
right so um I ended up staying but
during the year I kept asking um about
the money which maybe it would have
ended up being like 30 Grand in the end
oh yeah um 30 grand difference but it
was I don't even know what it was the
difference between like 100 and 130
which is decent when you're freaking
when you're freaking Cocker and then um
they just brushed me and then I was like
they they always had like they were like
you know if you're not if you're not on
the bus get off now I just remember
always been
like I'll just get off like I didn't I
wasn't buying into I was going my
hardest but I just knew that everything
that was coming from the top down wasn't
actually like they preach integrity and
stuff like that but they couldn't even
honor a handshake for such a significant
amount to the club but it was more just
the Integrity of the handshake they
wouldn't they wouldn't honor it yeah and
then um and then halfway through that
year which was my last year at the
Warriors they they gave offered me a
2-year contract um and it was it was
actually good money but I was a bit
stubborn in the head and I said oh put
30 grand on one of the years for for
this year which I lost and they're like
no we're not doing that and I was like
sweet well if you're not even going to
do that out of respect I'm not I'm not
staying and it was like a little bit
sour I was a bit sour I think they
probably like who
cares and um and then I ended up saying
I was leaving um and I was so pissed off
I remember that when they find out who's
leaving that you do interviews like in
the media and they're like oh you must
be said you're leaving and I was like no
I'm
happy those real like salty ones no I'm
happy I'm leaving and then like two
hours later there was like an article
that came out and I was like Char Go's
happy he's leaving the Warriors like
watch over there and I was like just
saing it [__] it doesn't look good but
um to the Warriors fful I love the
Warriors I was just uh salty at the time
so how did the Raiders come up oh cuz I
was originally gonna go link up with the
Cowboys uh with my old head coach Paul
Green Oh yeah and he was like yeah no
I'll sort you out um 2-year contract
like agreed on the money which was like
all good and then big I was still like
scared of him at the time like like you
know like principal thing cuz he used to
um like freaking Grill me when I was
young yeah I remember one time he came
to my house cuz I was like out of
form the house in Brisbane
and he was like sat sat me down I was
just about to have lunch and then he
like sat me down in the lounge and he
was like mate we got a sort out like you
he started so well blah blah blah and I
was just like I just I just got to do
something in the kitchen had the deep
fry going like I had many hot dogs in
there and he was like you fat [__] and
he was like this is why you out of
form and I was just like putting them
putting the hot dogs on a paper
tow just coughing that thinking like oh
hopefully he cool
down and then um he made me throw the
deep fry away I got back in formed
that's how how scared I was of him he
just like almost like a father figure so
you signed with the Raiders yeah signed
on the Raiders for a deep fry but um no
he said he was going to give me a
two-year contract um and I was like okay
sweet and then as the time ticked on I
didn't hear from him and then my I got
Frank to contact them and they're like
he was like oh they're not getting back
they're not getting back and then um
Ruben mie um who I got on with well he
was like man I'll I'll sort you out with
the Raiders cuz he Ruben was coaching
the Cup team at the time or like the
trainer I finished the season in cup
that's when um buy started playing me
and he came in and he was playing way
better than me um and then so I finished
the last few games in cup and then Ricky
rman is like who do you want to be a
Raider I was like yeah
brother we got no money left in the cap
so we have to be minimum and I was like
another year on minimum wage
okay I I suer for a minimum contract and
then so um I signed that and then um
stuff gets leaked all like so fast like
I signed it and then like um Paul Green
rang me and it was
like what the [__] did you just sign
with the Raiders like the same day and I
was like yeah and then he was like you
said you were coming here for two years
I was like oh I didn't hear from you
like I didn't hear from you and I was
scared and he goes no I was sorting out
I had to get rid of um maybe Patrick
KUSI oh brother um the brother of felce
he goes I had to sort that out he's
going to the stor blah blah blah and I
was like I I didn't know I didn't know
greeny I was like beding with him like
don't hit me he's like I thought our
friendship was worth more than that you
rank sticky and tell him you're not
coming and I was like I can't greeny
like I'm a man of my w he's like what
about the word you give to me like it
was it was like one of these
conversations but it was so hard for me
yeah cuz I was like who do I I just told
him that I was signing and I just signed
with the Raiders but then like
green is my day one but like also he
left like he was I think they just won
the comp or he was having a mean season
greeny was so he was probably on heaps
of money not worried about and but I was
the one worried about what the next step
for me was yeah so I was
like in hindsight I should have just
rung greeny and been like we still on
but like you don't think clearly
sometimes when you're under pressure
yeah and then um so I just went with I
was like a I can't I can't greeny blah
blah blah and he was like I'm off you
like he was actually off me true yeah he
was off me bro um and then it was that
was hard for me but I went I went and
went to Sticky um who I got on with man
went went to Raiders and ended up loving
my time there but um I always keept
thinking like man should have just
should have just picked up the phone so
that's probably a lesson for everyone if
there something uh you're not sure about
just grab your sack and just ring up
yeah and that was something you did sort
of your whole career like um early days
ringing up the Warriors and sending your
Clips out to all the teams like you were
confident enough to do that so it was
sort of out of character not for you to
um it's probably why you felt so sort of
bad about it h yeah yeah definitely I
don't I actually don't know what it was
you just have like those turning points
in your life I think like and I'm like
why the freak didn't I just ring greeny
like I we got on good like we were M but
I think I was just like maybe I felt
like nagging I don't know like are you
going to give me a contract like that's
not really how professional
for you going to give me a contract and
then Sticky's like M would love to have
you would like like just talking out his
ass you know like [__] you [__] we we
need like aggression blah blah blah and
I was like do you see that of me do you
see that what else do you see
me but um yeah and I signed death and it
ended up being all good yeah well you
said you loved it you didn't play a huge
amount over there like hardly played at
all to be fair I think you suspended for
a fair late shot on the best player of
the last decade clearing yeah yeah so I
um played my first game and then um I
tore my groin off the bone oh was that
is that legit injury cuz someone um said
the real fact was a circumcision um I
haven't had that injury
yeah he that but could be on the cards
could be on the cards guys um DM me of
the pros and
cons but um no I did I tore it off I
always had like groin like s what is it
like pubis or real bad groin injuries I
was always rehabbing it then we I played
versus the kns and I went to like get up
from a tackle and it just tore off the
bone and played on obviously
played on let in a try and then joged
back and then got dragged and then um
went and got scanned and they're like oh
that the whole thing's come off I think
it's like connected to your thigh like
down your groin like from up top and it
had pulled off and it took about eight
weeks to um
reattach and then I came back and played
maybe four games and then in the last
game versus
penth um I did had a pretty dirty tackle
on Ean Clary for by accident um cuz
what's his name sticky just keept saying
like I need you to pressure him you know
just when he's kicking pressure him and
um that was all that was in my mind and
then he's he's put up a mean bomb but he
stayed in the air for too long and I
attacked his legs in the air and then um
like I just got punished for that cuz I
already had like a real bad loading
system at judici like whenever you do
something and I done a lot in previous
years and then got a big ban and then I
just remember like mentally just going
downhill getting like coping it um
remember the one that pissed me off the
most was because pin was like blowing up
and then I remember me just like bite
like I always bite back and I just
started baring up and then after the
game I Tren me was saying something I
said oh sorry bro I didn't mean to um do
that and he goes nah it's just footy
mate it's nothing and then um I seen a
clip on Fox Sports and he was like it's
the most disgusting tackle I've seen
this year I was thinking you [__]
fat I was so pissed off and then um yeah
I just I got hammered for ages and that
took like a big toll mentally like
people just saying stuff about you you
know when you're not actually I wasn't a
big name player but I was getting a lot
of coverage for being dirty yeah um
which probably some of it was true but a
lot of it was said from people who have
no idea and that's one thing that you've
always sort of um I guess not enjoyed
about rugby league or is that media side
of thing even professional sport is that
media I know you're not a huge fan of
the um Fox commentary or some of the
stories they bring out um also keyboard
Warriors I know you're so anti against
all of these guys so like was that sort
of the start of all that for you no no I
think I've always been just
um like words like words hurt me
probably the most so even when they even
someone if someone is saying stuff about
someone that I know like it just makes
my my blood boil yeah so I don't know I
don't know what it is it's just how I am
like whereas I don't really like other
stuff I'm not I'm not bothered on do you
know what I mean like if someone's like
oh [__] someone said just rear ended
your car over
oh man that sucks but like oh someone so
said this about you I'll be like
what do you still get into the um social
media battles and I know you Renown for
making burner accounts and stuff to
troll the
trolls uh not really I don't need a a
burner account because um obviously I
don't have a blue Teck so um I still
Weir like differently
um reply to people that pissed me off
and my wife was like why do you do that
you feel better when you don't and I'm
like I actually feel better making them
feel bad
like that's just uh how I'm
built well that's good stuff so then you
eventually move over to the UK um try
and give super Lega guys this just cuz
you're basically sick of the media
you're you at a bit of a bottom and you
just want to try something new no no it
wasn't like to do with the media like I
don't know don't know where you got that
narrative Jimmy um it was just I was
sick of just I was mentally down like um
you know like I I've given everything to
the Warriors like we had a falling out I
could have stayed there for two years I
was I think it was just a snowball I
went to the Riders like [__] yeah Fresh
Start blah blah blah got that injury
came back started playing week to week
um then got banned again but I didn't
wasn't it wasn't something I intended to
happen and I got banned was getting
hammered and I was like [__] like I'm
and I remember like talking with some
other guys about it and they were like
the way you play you're always going to
get long bands now because just the way
did your sh was run so like if it was
going to be two weeks it would be 6
weeks for me just with the loading and
then I was like yeah I don't know just
in in my own head and then um my manager
was like oh do you want to go to the UK
I was like yeah and then
um then he goes oh I got you this good
deal which was like a grass deal like
too good for me but I was like I went to
Ricky um cuz he said oh you can stay
here for another couple years but like
it's not going to be good money so I
don't want to disrespect you yeah cuz
you're getting getting older and I was
like uh I do want to stay but also I
want some money um so and he goes oh if
I was you I would go to the UK cuz
that's like a really good deal and that
was with um Lee centurions at the time
they they were called Lee centurians and
they had like a millionaire owner cuz
they're all privately owned over there
the clubs it's not like they're run by
the union or something people buy the
clubs and they try and run them
profitably and this guy's pumping hips
of money and he a few NL players
and bod Thompson was there who I got on
with well he was like yeah come over bro
and I se me and my wife were like yeah
yeah we'll go over and we planned on
like having kids in there over there um
and just signing there for a few years
so I signed and then I remember right
before I flew out bod messaged me on
Whatsapp
um and he was like bro um I think we're
going into liquidation they can't like
the the owner's just like
gone gone off the grid and he's not
paying anyone true and I was like what I
didn't really understand it like CU I
was like oh isn't it owned by like the
competition and he was like no it's not
how it's blah blah blah and then it came
out on the media cuz cuz he had messaged
me and he was like looking forward to
having you here blah blah blah and then
I was and I was like yeah bro and he was
like what's he was like do you want this
car and I was like Audi G and I was like
yeah
bro make sure it's
automatic um this is like the comos we
were having like and he was seemed like
a good dude um and then all that stuff
came out and I was like just remember
messaging on WhatsApp and I was like if
you just blowing up and I was like
clicking on it like information read so
I know he was reading it and then um
yeah and then I was just rattled I went
went back to Wellington cuz obviously
that there was no
contract and then um Frank OT was like
we can chase it up with lawyers because
like officially like your contract is
lodged and there might be a way to make
his one of his other companies pay you
and he goes but we'll have to fly over
out of our own pocket and sort that out
and he goes the other option is you can
try get someone else to pick up the
contract yeah and then um woodness
Vikings ended up picking it up and I was
like looking at team like chrisan Aaron
hermiah Chris Alon like all these guys
that used to watch like oh yeah this
will be mean and then um I flew over got
picked up um and I was living with a
papa new guine guy called Wellington
Albert who was a freaking awesome dude
and I was like he was like I was like
what's it like here is it good we we a
good team and he was like ah n bro not a
good team and I was like they couldn't
really understand understand like his
definition of good team and then
um went to the CH I remember was like
Christian was like bro thanks for coming
thanks for coming I like what's it like
and he goes yeah we've lost 18 in a row
we playing in this million pound game
where you play versus like um the people
from the lower grade and if you lose you
go down and they take a million dollars
out of your Sal
account and I was like [__] and I just
remember like thinking I was like going
to be like a just car um but it was
freaking hard bro like they like
physical like guys definitely on
steroids and it was it was me like I
loved it like it was we played on like
AstroTurf like old a like tennis court
style yeah and I just remember just
getting cut up and I went a bit downhill
from there I got knocked out a couple of
times and they just kept making me play
um yeah it was kind of like it was it it
was a good experience like it made me
realize how how good things were in the
NRL and comparison yeah was that the
first uh few concussions that you'd had
was that the sort of first experience
with cion concussion you'd had no I'd
had I'd had a lot over um The Warriors
career cuz I always yeah I always just
LED with my head yeah but um probably up
until I was like 24 25 I'd never really
hit like I could I reckon I could get
hit on the head with a bat and it
wouldn't affect me and then just and
then just one I remember ver
um one of the burer brothers not the not
the Twins and not Sam the other one I
forgot his name that's George no maybe
Luke Luke oh Luke yeah Luke yeah I
remember um I just coming out of the
line and just had his hip collecting my
head and I was out for a long time like
I was knocked out and when I woke up
like I was on a stretcher and like um
someone was like pulling the hairs on my
leg and like rubbing a steel thing on my
foot and I couldn't feel it and I was
like so scared all right um I was like
kind of like crying on the inside like
just speechless but went to hospital
blah blah blah came
back everything was sweet like
everything was sweet it was just like I
just got so smashed that um um my body
was like oh man too many bats to the
Head uh and then I played two weeks
later and then after that I just like
kept like getting rattled yeah if you
know what I mean like my head strength
had just gone down yeah and I remember
like that was when hi had come in I'd go
for hi quite a bit and pass them and
then I'd be like pass the ti during the
week but then the same thing would
happen like I'd just be seeing Stars
blah blah blah and I remember like a
couple years later bod and Thompson was
saying to me bro you should um think
about having a year off like you're the
amount of hidden offs You' have had is
more than like people that I've played
with since you know I was young and he
he was a bit of a vet yeah and I was
like oh yeah no I will I will
bro not didn't really think anything of
it until um yeah then I think it did
have an effect on me big time actually
yeah that's interesting when you were
going out on the field were you feeling
sweet or did you know deep down that you
weren't quite right even though you're
going out there no I always felt sweet
like felt sweet you're just getting
knocked out way easier but I yeah yeah I
didn't um like I never changed like cap
used to tell me like you need to just
hold fire but like stop coming out of
the line yeah um because that's when
your head's getting rocked and I was
like yeah I I will do that but that was
kind of my thing like um just coming
from inside out or outside in yeah and
then um so I wasn't actually worried
like I didn't when I when I would get
like half knocked out I wouldn't care
like I'd just be like [__] was that a
good
shot that was kind of all I cared about
like did I did he fall
or and they be like no no he didn't like
okay uh yeah so that was all I was
really worried about and then um yeah I
probably went to England on a real bad
head space obvious see from CRA and we
me and my wife had um a few troubles
with what was to be our first child that
was like right before we went over too
so I was just rattled and like I didn't
handle that well like looking back I
should have just stayed you know when
something like that happens you don't
but I just kind of rolled over it so
what did you do no I went I went I went
to the UK oh going to the UK yeah yeah
yeah yeah but my wife stayed back cuz
she miscarried oh far out yeah so I was
like I think that's like how [__] up I
was mentally like to even come up with
that decision yeah like I was just
so was like trying to run away from
everything yeah and how was she how was
she throughout did she support that
decision or that's a hard decision to
support yeah yeah it wasn't like it
wasn't like a yeah it happened like a
few weeks beforehand
yeah it's just one of those things that
you learn and you learn from you know I
was
selfish um it was but I wasn't
intentionally doing it it was just where
my head was at at the time so you went
over by yourself I went over by myself
and I was thinking like she'll come over
the next year because things had fallen
through with the Audi truck and the
original club and she couldn't really
come over and love her with um the
brother um Wellington
um but then once we were playing like I
got knocked out a couple of times and I
remember like having like almost having
a punch up of the coach
because he said something to me but I
thought he was having a go at me cuz I'd
like hurt my
shoulder and then
um what happened I walked past the
coach's office and he goes how are you
and I was like and I'd just been knocked
out like twice and he was like are you
good to play and I was like to be honest
my shoulder's like pretty [__] and he
goes M you're always injured I love to
see you when you're not injured yeah and
then I thought he was saying that to me
like you're faking it yeah and I was
like yeah well you'd [__] be injured
too if you're playing like me come and
he like what and I was like yeah what do
you mean what like I was like what do
you mean what you want me to [__]
[__] your shoulder up right now is like
and the coaches like five coaches
they're like hey gby chill out mate I
was like no this guy and I was like
tearing up like that's how rattled I was
I was like crying like trying to get at
the cat and he was like I did not mean
that I did not mean that and then I was
like consol myself outside and then my
head I came up with this plan like okay
the CEO hasn't found out about this I'm
going to go towards the office I'm going
to ask for say I'm buying a house I want
a pay ons and then I'm just going to
take as much man as I can and fly home
and um I was like oh I went up to like
obviously dried my eyes I was like I
think his name was James I was like hey
James um my wife just we're just about
to settle on the house uh could I get
like a six month P Lance and he was like
oh we don't have the money and he goes I
can give you this amount and I was like
oh yeah that'll be fine just just send
it
through and then like um he sent me the
money and then I was just
like I was out bro what do you mean
you're out did you just fly home yeah I
didn't play the last game and then I
just went home and then that was it true
and you had another year to go yeah yeah
but they they ended up getting relegated
the boys ended up getting relegated but
um I could have gone back but I was just
like I couldn't like I'd already burnt
my bridges there like but they got rid
of that stuff and they weren't like the
Physio and that were cool ass I just me
and the coach obviously had that falling
out which is pretty hard to come back
from um
and that
was that was 50% him not knowing how to
uh talk to people and then 50% me being
mentally
unstable so did you realize at this time
that this was probably the end of your
career or were you happy to be walking
away at this point or you expecting to
keep playing no I was
like I just wanted to not play for a
while you know but I was I didn't have I
wasn't like oh I'm going to have a break
and try play again I was just like I
just need to go home cuz I wouldn't say
like I had depression but I didn't not
have depression a
you I was just and yeah I don't know
what like I knew that something wasn't
right with me yeah it sounds like
depression
but yeah yeah yeah I mean it takes a few
of the boxes you know um
yeah it took me a while to come right I
lived with my parents for ages and then
um it's kind of just floating around
Wellington but that was good for me like
just catching up with old mates and kind
of just doing things I did before I
started playing you know that working
for my old man and that sort of stuff
and then opportunities came up to go to
other teams on minimum wage but I was
got to the point where I was like man
like for me to play well cuz I wasn't
good enough to play at like 90%
intensity I had to go like I had to be
go so hard to be an NRL player to be NRL
quality whereas like a lot of my Ms they
were so good you know like that they
didn't have to be like almost insane to
play well just be like I was a bit off
tonight I'll be like [__] you're a good
bro yeah M was like you're off T like
[__] you wful you
know so I just it was just I don't know
it was like is the juice worth the
squeeze like what am I um what am I
trying to get out of this and like is it
going
to I don't know I just took a step back
and I was like I'd rather just still
work a normal job and be happy then play
inl and just be like anxious and where I
was at mentally at the time yeah did you
miss the locker room chat or by this
stage you were so you're struggling so
much mentally that you weren't really
enjoying that side of the game either
anymore no I did I did miss it but ever
like I was still like in all like I was
in like the Warriors group chat like the
Raiders group chat to cuz I was like you
know I was a main contributor so I was
in touch with everyone but um I don't
know yeah I did I did miss like the
actual I used to actually enjoy
preseason um when I was like focused and
just being around around people like
working hard but um I didn't have the
desire to do it again yeah if you know
what I mean it sounds weird like
ungrateful but it
was I don't know it's just so intense
and i' got to the stage where like when
I was putting myself in intense
situations like I was almost becoming
like too intense yeah well you can't go
into a preseason like you said half ass
cuz it's just so tough especially these
legal on that heard stories about man
just absolutely brutal you got to fully
commit to that did you um give Union a
go CU I remember obviously I was at the
Hurricanes at the time I remember
whispers about you potentially coming in
or um giving the NPC a crack was that
ever a real option for you
um I did I did come back and I played a
Club season and then I went up to um
rugby league park and I remember talking
uh walking past um Plum Tree who was the
coach of the canes yeah and he was like
let me know when you're ready mate and I
was like is this guy say I'm ready like
I'm ready and um it was uh I ended up
doing like heaps of training of um The
Academy but it wasn't like I don't know
the the academy was just Wellington
rugby Academy runs so [__] just like a
bunch of kids go go to the gym at 6:00
in the morning for free they get a
t-shirt [__] like the trainers freaking
mean but like they don't run it well
like they just go early to the gym and
do a gym
session and then like he was like yeah I
want you to come to Academy and learn
the game blah blah blah and then like
four days a week was just the German I
was fing man I'm already like already
built brother like already the finished
product to teach me the game um I was
ended up just freaking WR and like we do
wrestling sessions yeah and like I've
been wrestling for so long and I was
wrestling
18 year olds and stuff like that they
were doing their rest first session it
was um pretty crack up and then um I
didn't get taught anything about like
the game and I was thinking like okay
sweet it can't be that hard and then um
playing my first year with Maris um
prems like they' like kick the ball out
and I'd be like [__] like what do I do
here and they've already like formed the
line out and they're running and I'm
offside like just all that stuff and I
realized like okay no I'm going to be
ready for this I think you need to you
need to be um switched on for the game
like I could do the physical stuff and
um the tackling and the caring but I
just had no idea about like even when a
pod was running at me I'd be lining up
to hit the first receiver but obviously
it goes to the middle guy but that took
me like half a season to learn
like like yeah it was I don't know rugby
is
um I can see why people take so long to
adapt to it yeah you got to give it time
out I just saw um today kryon being
offered 1.6 to make the move like he's
someone um at similar position to you
built like you had can H someone like
him would go oh I think he would adapt a
lot faster than me like he's I think
he's a private school kid so he would
have played a lot of Union yeah H was
quite good at Union yeah yeah but even
still look at Roger as well he like it's
such a big difference from like going
playing school boy rugby then playing
NRL and then trying to play Super Rugby
do you know what I mean like you're
playing against kids people that have
been like training full-time and that
yeah and they seeing that same shape
over and over that's why I like have so
much respect for Roger even though
people like oh this that about Roger but
man like to
even be as good as he was and like he
was nowhere near his potential and Union
in my opinion but you just need time in
the settle do you know what I mean 100%
he's still he's still an all black like
not many people can say that yeah he's
right know pretty crazy him good you
think it's right call from and go back
to the Warriors He's going to be unreal
next year right yeah he's the man he
he's he's the man like um as a player
and as a person I I think like whatever
decision he made is the right decision
for him Cu uh I don't know he's just one
of those guys like he's just such a
genuine lad like he he he if you had him
he's he's the lad the ultimate lad yeah
he's the ultimate lad he's like
goldplated PS what is it PS 10
lad so then anyway you get into your um
portaloo business we've heard a little
bit about that but then what's the sort
of plans with that is that a big what's
your mission there give me the like the
sort of 10 year goal for you and your
Porter Kings yeah got the fiveyear plan
on there just oh five year okay let's go
far yeah no I just keep just keep
growing pretty much um I don't know it's
the Portal game by you know the Portal
game so well yeah man it can just flip
on its head in a
minute um no I enjoy it it's um
obviously I don't see
myself being in the truck forever but I
do enjoy like I I genuinely enjoy going
to people's sites and like just yarning
of them I got a Filipino guy that that
works for me and he kind of does the
cleaning and I do the
yarning that's the way that's perfect
for you yeah yeah and what expanding it
like obviously it's it's mainly in
Wellington at the moment or only in
Wellington yeah only in Wellington no I
think I'll just stay in Wellington
there's enough like stuff down here in
witon I mean I don't want to be too
greedy you know I was happy with a
minimum wage uh in I'll I can't be too
greedy and go for you know that Max P
contract right think I think you could
be a bit more ambitious I think there'll
be a lot of people especially down in
Christ Church after a Charlie gab
portaloo I don't know we'll see we'll
see what sort of feedback it gets you
know might send a couple down on the
inter
Islander yeah oh man well that's that's
good stuff and what a mate what a story
I didn't realize there's so much um
going on in your G especially how long
it took you to sort of crack it but um
what a cool y but obviously thousands of
questions for you mate like looking
forward to this I know we've gone a
little bit longer than I probably
expected to but and we'll try and fly
through some of these yeah yeah ask
Charlie if he's done any hard Army
Camps yeah I've done some
harder I don't know who that's from
but at Warriors this is we did camp at
pretty much all the teams but Warriors
we did this thing called um campal yeah
Camp pal and we did it twice the first
time they said uh oh we're going away
for like a team bonding
camp and we're like oh this is good
everyone's going and then we we met up
in papur at this like lunch room we're
having nice lunch and then they just
like took groups away and like put bags
over their heads but like we don't know
just saw like I remember someone goes
[__] they they're putting bags on their
heads and everyone was like [__] we're
doing an army camp and um we got out
there and they're like you know like get
on the ground you piece of [__] like
talking to you like that and we're like
okay how hard can it be blah blah blah
so we do like burpees BL does it at like
12 o'clock in the afternoon like do
burpees and then they go okay everyone
has to do whatever it is like 100
push-ups um 1K Run 100 burpees blah blah
blah and I go and then we're done and
we're like oh what the okay sweet so we
did it and then they're like who didn't
do them all put your hand up and then
like no one put their hand up and then
they're like because we had people
watching and like all the people came
out that were watching like
hiding like who didn't who didn't do
them all and then like some people like
put their hand up and they're like okay
you guys stand over there and then there
was some people that didn't put their
hand up you guys stand over there too
like they goes everyone that did them
all you're going to keep doing bpes and
these people are going to watch you man
that probably went from like 4:00 to
like 630 holy at night and then we're
like okay sweet that's it and it was
just like I don't even know what
happened over the next 3 days but there
was like no sleep they like sleep
deprived us right and then um just made
us do like real real real real hard
stuff that you you wouldn't think you
could do like carry you know like tires
and logs and I remember like putting it
on my shoulder and being like oh [__] I
prob carry this like 5 m and they're
like all right we're going
20K and they're like and if it touches
the ground like West diing again and
you're just like in so much pain after
like 5 seconds but you somehow you just
keep going yeah blah blah blah doing
that and you got calluses on your feet
and the last one that was actually saved
the day was like
midnight and there was 40 of us I think
there was 40 people on the camp and they
had
38 um 20 L cans and you just so in lines
of 20 you had to like pass them up to
the end until the end person didn't have
one he had to run to the front oh hell
yeah yeah and we he were supposed to
travel 2K doing that so like 2K of
passing the things and then one group
kept dropping
it and then that group was like um n
little muppy saliva havil and this this
guy Brad Abby and it was between saliva
Nani and Brad that they kept dropping it
and every time they drop it they had to
do 10 burpees and everyone was
like [__] you n
like and he's like it's not me it's Brad
and I just he abused Brad so bad like
but like no one cared because we were so
tired and then um I remember him what he
said was Brad you're the weakest [__]
I've ever met in my life and Brad was
like it's not me it's not me and in like
10 seconds later caav like passed out
and just went face first into the
concrete and like everyone was like like
to the staff like [__] you like look
what you did to our brother and they
were all like [__] themselves cuz he
like smacked his he on the concrete and
he was like pulsating on the ground
through like lack of sleep dehydration
blah blah blah and then they're like all
right everyone go inside and they had a
meeting and they're like you can sleep
now for 4 hours and we're like soaking
wet everyone just like went to sleep but
iron was like thanks L like he came back
from hospital they're like he's all
right guys we're going to continue on
thans leave like dapping them
up we still talk about that now I still
think about the the abuse that some of
the boys cop all for keeping his mouth
quiet mate no wonder you didn't want to
do another
preseason yeah we did that same camp the
next year too and after
yeah torture okay there's a good one
okay next one ask him about when he
spent $300 on an outfit for a
Daye oh [__] that was when I was living
with um Sam ly and I was like oh can I
borrow some clothes like blah blah blah
and then he's like no let's just go to
the thing like little did I know he's
just taking the piss out of me seeing
like what I thought was cool and how
much money I was going to spend and I
brought like a
um I don't know like a pair of like
Federation jeans and a rip kill t-shirt
or something and then like went on the
day obviously came home at like 9:30 and
like how was it yeah never heard from
her
again oh money well spent okay next one
why did he always leave skid marks in
the toilet Chad townsan Chad townzen oh
that's Chad he I lived with Chad for a
couple of years oh did you yeah he was
yeah but I didn't I did not lose good
marks but one time I came home from he
was obviously playing in RL and I think
I came home from a cup game and he had
done a I think an Aussie they call it
reverse kangaroo where they go backwards
on the toilet and the whole his whole
freaking his whole thing was on the back
of the toilet like gone rock hard and I
was just filthy like just got it
obviously and this inspired you to start
a portly business from that be a we way
to clean
this okay next question uh tell us about
the time you rated yourself too highly
oh yeah yeah yeah I know who this is
um this was uh at the Warriors when
Steve Kerney took over he had this board
like every day after training you had to
rate yourself 1 to 10 on how well you
trained like he must have brought it
back from the storm it might have worked
for them but it definitely didn't work
for the
lads um and then so obviously 10 being
like the best game game ever played and
one being I don't know like you punched
the rift before before the game and you
did not play so there's 10 and then
there's one and to be a NRL player you
need to be above six every time yeah and
then so like trainings everyone was
always too ashamed like even if they had
a mean training you know because you
didn't want to be the guy that gave
themselves a seven and then because how
we' do it too you'd rate yourself you're
not your rating will be there and then
it' pull back the curtain and then his
rating for you would be
there and then like a couple of times
people would give them themselves a
seven you know and you get a six and you
just get
like um and there was one I always used
to just give myself a six like and
deservedly I was a six um and then we
played we played the dragons um one day
cuz you did it on game day and it was
the week that like Benny and a few boys
got done for taking prescription drugs
with um
Red Bull as you do you know as you do
okay um so they got we were missing five
of our W players and we were meant to
lose the game it was quite a like
emotional game and I remember like going
so hard I scored a try I scored a try
and did like some [__] like some good
tackles like right in front of the bench
like you know put the elbow on put a lot
of [__] on and then Benny came up to me
after the game and he goes bro you were
a seven or an eight and then I was like
do you reckon and he goes easily I was
talking to the boys we reckon like that
might have been an eight that might have
been an eight and I was like nah I'm not
going to say eight and then he was like
do it man do it like it'll be [__]
mint if you do
eight and then so I did seven I did
seven and I was like okay so hopefully
I'm an eight and he like pulls back the
curtain
five and I just remember looking over B
and I was
like so cut like so embarrassed I got
dropped the next week I
was and I was thinking like [__] does
this guy just G me out he's just like
pissing himself laugh
me so I probably never forgive for that
one was it a genuine stit up or was he
did he genuinely think you played well
no he like cuz me and him got the same
idea like playing well is like you know
putting a bit of her in putting a bit of
niggle in but um
probably I wasn't putting it in the
right areas you know I probably wasn't
finding my front tying and kick chase
that sort of stuff I was more just in
the emotion of my five best mates
getting dropped and absolutely destroyed
in the
media oh that is good stuff okay next
one um best Yan from his time on Sweet
Georgia yeah I don't know I definitely
had like some good times on there but
can't think of any any like lad stories
okay here's one uh I went on his old
man's boat once and he told me a Yan
that he had a fling with Helen Clark is
this
true no no no no what the
heck I'm guessing you just spun like
that many yarns on those um
boats yeah yeah freak yeah I I probably
did say
that and hindsight I don't think um I
don't think Helen's my
TP what's the worst state you've ever
picked a low up in oh man like I've only
been in the game for a year and a half
but I definitely test your character um
that Wellington W probably two weeks ago
we had this wind that was like
190k on the Sunday and I was thinking
like [__] here we go here we go it's
Camp H again um woke up there was
already like 15 Miss calls at like 700
a.m. and then like I just like remember
going to this guy's site CU I was like
oh you can uh clean it yourself you can
clean it yourself for free and I just
like or I can clean it for 200 it's up
to you and I like you clean it I was
like [__] all right when under there
clean it and I remember it was just so
rank he's like how do you do this and I
this is me it's not actually that bad
just get those soft
bristles and I just like gagging my head
I'm thinking like man this I'm probably
going to get cancer from this but it's
all it's all part of the gig
M it's not all you know it's not all
Instagram content and dropping off
toilets what's what's the cancer theory
is that from the smell just all the
chemicals that I'm using to clean it
like I'm like breathing in like you know
I always watch freaking YouTube videos
like this guy got cancer using Roundup
and I'm like [__] round up I'm using
the this [__] this shit's serious
oh it's good stuff okay next one where
do you treat yourself on Fridays every
Friday I go to um Co Bernie baras did
you are did you ever go there I used to
go there yeah Mark absolutely yeah yeah
with Mark and we always
just obviously debrief on what's going
wrong with society and whatnot um always
get a packet of camels or Dunhill switch
and me Mark CTI couple of other guys
Valentine OG there he just um yarning
and [__] just power through the CES
power through the siggies and then it
gets to like six o00 absolutely tanked
and I got to Charlene's texting me come
home you're you know you're on you're on
Bath Duty I go home just take the top
off anything that smell I like sigy take
it off at the door I'm going in on my
undies after the kids fall asleep with
them that's a standard
Friday oh that's Ling okay next one
fastest player you've played with Glen
fish easy oh the fish he was quick the
20s in his prime yeah okay toughest
player you played with played with
um overall
toughness s mannering oh yeah but um
tough the guy I used my captain on in
the water lead League team Jack wden oh
yeah I've been watching him ever since
you picked him up and yeah he is tough
he must have smoked you at a young age
cuz did he yeah you always remember who
smokes yeah but no he didn't smoke me he
didn't smoke me but um I'm just I don't
know maybe he did maybe maybe it was the
straw that broke the camel's
back it was one of those a thousand head
knots okay the goat Warrior this could
be similar answer is that the goat
Warrior um for me Ben melino oh man Maro
the hit man yeah he's three time player
of the year I think people forget how uh
how dominant he was in a team that
wasn't going
well um and summer mening and then
obviously have to put uh like sj's in
the conversation now yeah what a year
yeah maybe Warrior big fan of Manu
V
yeah TR scoring machine yeah he's a
machine for start
brother
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a wood Le listener oh yes
advice um these are all hopefully going
to go on a book one day and I reckon
Charlie GBS is going to be the first one
almost like the the back cover I didn't
prepare for this so so probably just as
he pulls out his
notebook well I didn't prepare for this
babe bring that
over
probably just like um have you seen the
movie pursuit of happiness yeah I have
we you know when he's telling his son
like when you got a dream just hold on
to it you know don't let um don't let
people get in the way of you and your
dream like even if it's delusional like
it'll the universe or God if you're God
for a man like myself will uh put things
on place that will uh help get you there
if you stay stay on course of your dream
oh I knew it that's the first chapter of
the wood
lead best piece of advice but quotes
because that is that is good even if it
is from a movie like that is impressive
like what a way to finish one of the
great podcast like I did mention at the
start we've been I've been hanging out
for this for working at least two years
and absolutely worth the wait that was
absolute laugh and um some real
seriously good Y and awesome to hear
your story too by the way like I I knew
bits of it but um no it was a crazy
crazy we journey you've been on and
awesome to see you doing so well with
the um Porter Kings and looking forward
to following that hopefully expanding
the country and um the place where
everyone should be getting their portal
from oh thanks Jamma for being on I'm
not
sure you know if we we covered uh
anything worthwhile but maybe we can do
a little collab watero something like
that down the track um
yeah I don't know I like what a mate it
it was it was awesome being on and I was
I was nervous and I hopefully I've I've
pulled it off being on the on the on the
guest but I'm not I'm not sure that I
have oh you've absolutely nailed it this
is this thing that you've had throughout
your whole career you've played so well
but you always feel like you haven't
done enough you've got like this
impostor syndrome but mate that was the
best
ever oh yeah well my brother will be the
first to let me know if it was decent or
not I appreciate it mate no all good
thanks Jamma thanks for help me brother
you're a lead